deputy FBI at the FBI director Andrew
McCabe just wrapped up with the house
Intel committee after get this seven and
a half hours behind closed doors
McCabe may hold the key to unraveling
the entire insurance policy text between
Peter struck and his mistress Lisa Paige
joining us now to analyze solo Eisenberg
a former deputy independent counsel who
conducted grand jury questioning a
President Bill Clinton in the Whitewater
investigation he joins us now Saul wow
seven and a half hours even if I am a
little tongue-tied at the top there so
I'm gonna have hours for McCabe what
does that tell you if anything it tells
you they're very angry at him I mean
you're talking about a person who
wouldn't understand the conflict of
interest if it jumped up and bit him on
the butt and they probably been waiting
to talk to him for a long time I mean my
god you're talking about a lawyer whose
wife took seven hundred thousand dollars
from a Clinton crony and he refused to
recuse himself from the Clinton
investigations until there was a Wall
Street Journal story about it and by
then it was too late they were closed
well Republicans more of them are coming
closer at least one calling for him to
step aside I think a lot of folks are
hesitant to say that about Muller
although some are but it seems to me
given everything we know about McCabe
from his wife to the conversation or
they learn something about that
conversation I imagine that took place
before the election that mr. struck was
referring to in those texts about an
insurance policy and at this point I
think he's the he's the weakest link at
the FBI in this current situation
Laura nobody over at the bureau can
believe I talked to former agents I
talked to people who are currently at
the bureau nobody can believe that he's
still there it's astonishing that he's
still there
I wouldn't tarnish Muller I noticed you
didn't pass up the opportunity the
tarnish Bob Muller with McCabe I
wouldn't do that
Muller has nothing to do with the things
that McCabe did before Muller came on to
the scene if you talk about the insurer
texts the insurance policy text from
Strock what possible innocent
explanation is there he says we can't
take the risk that Trump will be elected
we can't take the risk I mean how can
you there there are only embarrassing
and more embarrassing explanations
there's no completely innocent
explanation for that
worst case scenario with sorry go ahead
no no I think yeah go ahead the worst
case scenario is they were trying to
they're trying to stop Trump from
becoming elected right get that FISA
warrant on a phony basis of that dossier
but they're trying to say now through
various sources going to the Wall Street
Journal that they were actually trying
to in a way help Trump if he were
elected by getting written finished with
this investigation correct that is
ridiculous they're they're also saying
I've also heard a rumor floating around
that the the insurance policy was for
them to keep their jobs which is equally
ridiculous an FBI agent doesn't have to
worry about I know
an FBI person at that level doesn't have
to worry about keeping their job in a
new administration unless they've
committed malfeasance so unless he was
worried about his handling of the
Clinton email investigation I'm talking
about Strock now he had nothing he had
nothing to worry about it's a
preposterous explanation I suppose the
best explanation the most innocent
explanation is we can't take the risk
that he's going to get elected and not
let us investigate him so let's get this
investigation started now but even there
it's obvious they're rushing things
they're not doing it the right way and
the meticulous way I have a question for
you so why wouldn't Jeff Sessions at
this point fire McCabe I mean he that
doesn't bear on the Russian
investigation and he recused himself
from the collusion investigation but why
couldn't he fire fire McCabe now he
could right well he has the power to
fire McCabe I've heard different things
about how broad his recusal was and I
mean one interpretation is he said I
won't have anything to do with the
election at all
I suppose somebody could say well that
has to do with the election
oh it's Rob but I think he I think he
could do it but look I President Trump
can call up Christopher Rea and say the
guy shouldn't be there and he has
already did that he's yeah he'll be
attacked for it so he he says he's
attacked for everything yeah he won't do
it he won't do it and I think you're
probably right
in the end he probably he probably
shouldn't solve thank you so much
another great great analysis